- Please buy me that pink food.
I would like that pink food please.
Put it in my mouth, thank you.
(chirping)
- I'm so excited.
- We are trying limited
edition Peeps Oreo cookies.
- Limited edish'
- I guess I'm surprised that
there's no Oreo based religion
because Oreos are so freaking
good that they make me
believe in something.
- I'm big on color.
That's a thing that
Peeps do have to offer.
- I like Peeps more than Oreos.
The sugar coated crust, it's the best.
- An Oreo dunked in milk is
one of the finest pleasures
on Earth.
- Peeps, Oreos, two things
I would never have thought
to combine but, you know, maybe
it's a match made in heaven.
- I think I'm ready to Peep those cookies.
- [Both] Ah,
- It smells like happiness.
- It smells like play-doh.
- But it also smells like Halloween.
- It smells like cake frosting.
- If my life could smell
like this everyday,
it would be a good life.
- There is no sugary crust.
- Here we go, wow.
- Oh, I'm into it,
- The texture of the little,
like, pop rocky sugar in there
that's like a little party.
- Just tastes like cake frosting.
- I feel like my dentist is
somewhere right now, very upset.
- I do like the cookie,
the cookie is classic.
- The cookie tastes like a trefoil.
- Like a what?
- A trefoil, it's a girl scout cookie,
and that's what this tastes like,
and I'm kinda into that.
- I do appreciate the texture.
- I mean, I love this, I
would rank it above a Peep
and below a normal Oreo, but really A+.
- I'll probably eat them again.
- Here's the thing, Oreo, you
don't need to better yourself,
you're just perfect the way you are.
- I admire the collaboration,
good partnership,
actually, I'm gonna have another one.
(upbeat music)
- I wanna see a Doritos flavor of Oreo.
Cool ranch Oreos?
- That's disgusting.
- Wow!